okay so spider-man no way home is now
out on 4k blu-ray and after i picked up
the new steelbook last week i've gone
through the film with the fine-tooth
comb to find some insane details in it
huge thank you to everyone who checked
out our last easter egg video which had
some multiverse breaking cameos to bring
you almost every hidden detail in the
film however there was still more to be
unearthed and throughout this breakdown
we'll be going through 50 new things
that i'm pretty sure haven't been
mentioned anywhere else so sit back
strap yourself in and come with us as we
do another another breakdown of
spiderman no way home now the movie
brings across several villains from the
marvel universe in order to make one of
the best comic book showdowns ever
though we don't get a shirtless doctor
octopus we do get things that go beyond
just the characters coming back and many
of the makeup techniques are reused from
prior movies in the original spider-man
film willem dafoe pretty much took on
two personas in both norman osborne and
the green goblin in order to subtly
differentiate between the two the
costume department actually gave him
fake teeth to straighten up his grin
when he was being the guy that was
somewhat of a scientist himself however
when he stepped into the green goblin
persona these were removed so that
defaults sharp incisors and the gap in
the middle could be seen on display this
is something that also pops up in no way
home and when norman is putting together
the cures we can see that his teeth are
fake throughout it whereas when tom
holland is punching him later his grin
has the gap in the middle now this cure
scene also has lots of hidden details in
it that showcase why the cure didn't
work for him huge shout out to canadian
live for pointing out that we get a
scene in which we can see how far along
the cures are for the villains max
dylan's gets completed whereas we can
see that norman's is only about 80 done
it's a really cool detail that explains
why may injecting him had no effect and
beyond that i actually think that goblin
never wanted it to work this is because
we get the excellent scene with doc and
osborne where he clearly hints towards
him being the only one in control
how does it feel norman
you're about to become whole again
no more darker half
just you
just me
therefore i think that i was born
purpose he didn't want to cure himself
and no matter what had happened he never
would have created one that could have
taken out the goblin this is why the
cure only works later on when toby steps
in because he's figured out a way to
undo everything in him without him
meddling in the process again huge shout
outs to canadian lad for that initial
detail the guy's done an absolutely
amazing breakdown on the movie that
actually made me mad to watch it because
of how good it was i even had to drop
some details because of it so go check
it out after this if you want to see
some things that you missed and by you i
mean me see you chump
toby maguire is a massive part of the
movie and now there's lots of callbacks
to his character that are on the nose
there's two really subtle ones that i
haven't seen pointed out in any other
breakdown when peter first enters the
donut shop mj waves at him but this is
revealed that it's actually to ned jump
back to the first spider-man movie and
we get a scene in that in which mj waves
are peter but it's actually to her
friends standing behind him in the
credits when we get the cast drawings
there's one of mj and this has several
markings on it there's the sketch that
she drew of peter in detention on the
left-hand side
fragments of his letter just below it
and clearly she's wondering who peter
parker is however if we look in the top
right corner you can see that the words
who am i or written upside down which
with the magic of editing will now flip
around now who am i is a really
important phrase in the spider-man
universe as it's the line that opened up
the first spider-man film
who am i
you sure you want to know
the story of my life is not for the
faint of heart
otobi's experience is shown throughout
the movie and there's a ton of subtle
little things that the vfx artists do to
really flesh out the characters after
andrew and toby about the electrocuted
the ladder kneels down in pain or as the
former manages to stand on his feet and
recover quicker this is because in his
own universe he insulated elements of
his suit so that he was more resistant
to electricity when andrew and toby
dropped down to meet tom for the first
time if you zoom in and follow the
ladder on his fall you might notice a
subtle little thing he does toby
actually touches the ledge for a split
second to slow his descent i think this
detail is absolutely brilliant whereas
andrew just drops down normally toby
runs his hand on it for probably less
than a second and it just shows how he's
much more precise during the bridge
fight scene peter ends up catching the
car before it dangles over the edge and
he strains to hold it in place knowing
that ok is right around the corner he
can't spend long doing this so he throws
a web bomb which he attaches the first
web too this then explodes and throws
webbing between the smash segments of
the bridge holding the car in place so
that peter can go off and face otto
there's also a brilliant moment when
andrew gets blasted by electro whilst
he's on top of the statue of liberty as
he goes flying you might notice that his
foot is on fire and this is because a
piece of the top that was covering it is
stuck to his soul the statue of liberty
is made from copper and thus if it was
hit with a bolt of electricity it would
become a conductor which would generate
heat
storm fry them
oh yes a bolt of lightning into a huge
copper conductor
i thought he lived at the school
so the top would set on fire and as
andrew is acting instinctively he hasn't
really thought about disengaging the
suction on his feet if it sticks to him
whilst it's still on fire the statue is
also bronze rather than being its
typical green but this is actually the
color that it was originally you might
have noticed on some pennies that they
turn green after some time and this is
because the element reacts to oxygen in
the air which changes its pigmentation
the same thing happened with the statue
however it's being cleaned up as part of
the renovation work in order to add the
shield now speaking of shields when we
could to happy's apartment we can also
catch the one from iron man 2 in the
security feed there's also happy's
boxing equipment which he wore in that
movie and happy in the comics was a
boxer which kinda ties into that really
good attention to detail there and
another great one in the apartment
happens with electro later on just
before the tv turns on if you zoom in on
his hand you can actually see that he
shoots out a tiny almost imperceptible
geld of electricity to power it up such
a cool detail that's really difficult to
catch there's also tom's suit which we
see dissolve into his belt device when
he lands on the bridge hidden just under
his jacket the nanotech retracts into it
and if you look at his shadow on the
left hand side you can also see that
changes along with him as the costume
retracts this leaves peter's suit really
wrinkled and we also see the wrinkles on
his blue shirt later on when he's in the
sanctorum carrying this detail over all
those creases i think he needs an iron
man eh
[Music]
oh wait he's dead anyway the movie ends
with peter somewhat also being dead as
he completely removes the memory of
himself from everyone's mind now
throughout the film there are several
shots that hinted how mj ned would
continue their friendship and when
damage control first showed a maze we
get a quicker of a photograph of the
pair from the prom this later shows up
at ned's grandma's house i think it's
really interesting how the photograph is
just of the two it's completely missing
peter and they could pretty much keep
this up around their house without ever
questioning why it's there peter ends up
going to mj with a speech that he's
clearly practiced later on and this
shows he learned from his mistake
earlier in the movie of not preparing
his mit speech i mean like the
the dumber version of me that wouldn't
have let them help
you didn't rehearse that did you peter
now he does this so he doesn't forget
what he wants to say and speaking of
forgetting hey it's actually possible
that strange makes peter forget him
messing up the spell
you changed my spell six times five
times you changed my spell you don't do
that i told you and that is why
i love this little line and it could
show that strange carried out the spell
six times instead of just the five this
might be because when strange said he
wanted the entire world to forget that
he'd be included in this too however he
wanted to remember peter so he altered
the spell for himself made peter forget
about it and then continued with the
other ones might be a reach but i have
to include that detail in the video
because i do quite like that theory now
the last thing i want to talk about is
happy things are getting foggy hogan
throughout homecoming we watched as he
was a punk to peter and he constantly
ignored his calls however in no way home
after the apartment scene happy ends up
calling peter but he can't get through
thus he leaves a voicemail and well well
well how the turntables now let's end
with a joke who does peter meet at aunt
may's grave at the end of the movie
sad hogan anyway that's the video and
all the extra details that we could find
in it if you enjoyed it then we'd
massively appreciate the thumbs up and
also don't forget to subscribe for
breakdowns like this every week as i
mentioned at the start of the video we
did a big easter egg breakdown on the
film a couple of weeks ago and it's good
appearances by eric voss emergency
awesome ryanairy grace randolph
everything always cosmic wonder denim
nerds real rejects soups and a lot more
it's our best video on the channel so
definitely go check it out right after
this it's on screen right now and i'm
actually getting annoyed mate yet you
should be there now what are you doing
in the video in the video get over there
now go get go get punk